okay we're back we're still talking
x-men Days of Future past this time
we're talking spoilers which means that
we don't have to tap-dance around what
what I was gonna say our issues but it's
gonna be their issues cuz they come core
issues with this movie then I do mine
are few and far between I was very happy
and I feel like you guys enjoyed it
somewhat so what did work for you
oh one of the things that I thought
works
would that worked well for me one of the
things that I enjoyed immensely was the
I thought the threat of the Sentinels
was established well I thought they did
it early in the film they showed us a
few of them they showed us humans that
I'd argue administered care about but
mutants too nonetheless fighting and
failing to defeat these things in fact
being killed by the Sentinels and later
on when you show us a whole army of them
I am concerned when Iceman had his head
taken off and he and his frozen head
skids across the floor I kind of had his
oh oh okay I wasn't shocked that he
would die because I knew I knew going in
the crux was gonna be changed the future
so any character we see in the future
timeline can be killed I knew that
coming in but to see it done that
brutally for lack of a better term I was
like okay yeah all right and I liked I
liked the basic premise of the movie I
it's it's an old story but I liked the
the setup that they need to send a
mutant back to avert this dystopian
future and I liked most of the time I'd
like the parallels between them and I
liked when we saw certain ramifications
from the past and infringing on the on
the future timeline well I know for you
I I could hear you jittering next to me
what during quicksilver's big scene
which is easily the showstopper and the
I think the highlight of the film and
the the it was very clear that everyone
that worked on that particular scene
loved it it is it was probably fun to do
it was probably fun to accident to
animate the and it was fun to watch
everyone the audience
join it the there I don't think there
was anything you could have done better
in that particular scene it was pretty
much aside from the story issue
associated with it um any perfect moment
in that thing
yeah I mean almost a perfect character
introduction you know in terms of like
here is a real example of what he can do
here it is this is what it could look
like and this is also why we can't use
him in the rest of the movie but I
understand the you know you're not the
first one to bring it I've seen it
mentioned elsewhere that boooo well why
do they behind was like well because
it's a logical problem it's the same
reason that Harry Potter can't have the
time turn around the third movie because
it fixes everything okay so the plan is
to stop the assassination of all of our
Trask and that is going to prevent the
creation of the Sentinel program Peter
Dinklage but he had already created
sentinels before that Trask should not
have been the target for mystique and I
think that had more to do with the fact
that we've got Peter Dinklage we need to
use him right we need to make him a
bigger part because I don't know if he's
the guy you kill off in order to do this
it seems like he's the guy who pulses on
the opportunity when a president or
somebody else has killed off your you're
correct but also remember mystique was
not after him to stop the seminal
program mystique was after him because
he'd been experimenting on mutants and
she knew that so she was after him for
revenge they were trying to stop
mystique because that self this whole
other thing
Jean when she was first trying to kill
him she knew nothing about Centon
program she didn't know she didn't care
she was gonna kill him no matter what
which is actually part of the problem
later on because even being told what
was gonna happen she still like no I
need to kill this guy at least for a
little while right which undermined her
whole character and there were a lot of
people acting stupidly a mystique was
one the other one is Erik Magneto sorry
later on when he decides that at all
costs he has to kill mystique even in a
brutal open battle in front of the
embassy on live television although I I
have to be honest I don't get
of the reasoning for what Eric does well
I understand why he way to kill her he
can easily capture beasts right and hold
him down he could grab anybody there
he threw cops around but he has to kill
mystique with magneto is he does not
have a ton of time to plan he gets
busted out told what's going on and then
they're in Paris almost immediately so
he's coming up with a plan on the fly as
best as he's able to with information
that is kind of insane into this movie
he's doing something and I feel and it
feels crazy it feels like it comes out
of left field and for me there's this
and I talk about this at the moment in
the plane right where he's got he takes
control of the airplane and he's
screaming at Charles in that beat is
where you tell the audience that humans
are the secondary like evolutionary
backwater and that we are now going to
rise up and this is where we're gonna do
and he doesn't do it he doesn't do it
and he doesn't tell us and so that when
we get to that point in the movie we're
like wait a minute we thought he was on
the site of you know saving people we
they made him a hero like great he say
he tried to save Kennedy but yes but
they also had to drop that line that
Kennedy was actually mutant which makes
it all very consistent it's not it's the
status quo is not enough he needs to put
the mutants on the table now again I if
you want to pick holes in what his plan
is and how it's gonna work out I'll
admit it's not it's not foolproof but I
think I think given what his goal is and
that his goal is not sick is his goal is
not what everyone else's goal is
everyone else's goal is prevent this
future his goal is I'm completely
rewriting this entire book because they
just want it to be what it is now that's
not enough for me so him taking it a
step further you have to keep in mind
he's not taking a step further because
he doesn't think they're not doing
enough to save the future he thinks that
the future they're trying to save isn't
the future that he wants he the future
he's fighting for is not the future
everyone else is fighting for because I
give that line too
to Charles that I don't want that I
don't want your food
yeah is Charles's Lang and it should be
Eric's okay that's yeah but I just
touching back on Peter Dinklage he was
part of the reason I went to talk about
actors I want to see you stuff and I
thought he was grossly under used I
thought that we had no emotional
connection with Trask in any way what I
mean by that is we had no firm
understanding of why Trask wanted the
mutants dead for a story about the
Sentinels you need a human element to
the story and Trask was it and we didn't
get any human connection to him I don't
think it's a particularly emotional
choice for him it's it's a simple
question of survival it's like yes these
people are the next evolution in
humanity but that means we go away
it's a very cold very scientific
approach to it as opposed to sort of the
more gut level emotional oh my god I'm
scared of these things of which is what
we have usually gotten with the human
villains in in these movies and in the
comics but for the sake of drama I would
rather have that emotional response than
the cold scientific one for me I don't
think I knew because I think we were
getting enough emotional weight out of
the actual mutant characters and just
from enough conflict that was going on
with them for the one so the one thing
that bothered me the movie ended the one
thing the one really right now that
we've gone through 50 others right what
was on the movie ended I had to say
there was one glaring issue for me and
the group for me it was that they're the
ticking clock in the quote real world a
future time or the future right was
essentially non-existent the group had
made it to the safe house in Tibet I
don't know okay and they're okay right
the Sentinels aren't there the Sentinels
aren't coming apparently I don't know
where they are they do eventually show
up but the problem was is that we would
go back and forth between these places
and we would see them there and aside
from Wolverine stabbing Kitty Pryde
there
wasn't anything bad sort of going on
there and I desperately wanted something
bad to be going on there because I
needed for for what Katie and what
Wolverine were doing to be under
pressure to be under stress so that when
we went back to the real world I would
be worrying about what was happening
there and there wasn't really a time
where I worried about it until we got to
the very very end where it felt like way
too late if I like it was like okay now
it's a threat now there there's a
problem but now it's like way too much
like it's a thousand you know sentinels
are crying and so that was the the one
issue I walked out of the movie with at
that moment and then I started to think
about a little more I feel like in Korea
member I'm really you guys basically
needed the six hour miniseries version
of this story well I feel like a story
like this
demands it well I um see I came away
satisfied but I'm just and I'll I'm not
gonna call this a fault but this is just
me I'm a guy who is okay with not all
the dots being connected not that I'm
saying you guys need your hands held I
don't mean to belittle you like that but
I kind I kind of like holes like I like
I like not knowing exactly how Charles
and Aaron came to resolve their
differences because of what's more
important is the contrast between where
they are where the relationship is in
the 70s versus where it is when as far
as they're concerned they're at the end
of their lives it's that's contrast
that's important not necessarily what
event caused them to then be okay with
each other
so I'm I'm I just as a viewer personally
am more okay with those kinds of holes
again I might have been more forgiving
of some of these problems if I didn't
have so many problems I found fault with
NASA every years
well interestingly enough most of the
things that you said you had issues with
in this are the things that I'm worried
about for x-men apocalypse hmm because
look because here's the thing we're
going to so whether you think they did
it well or not this is a two hour 20
minute very complicated movie mm-hmm I
mean this is a complex complicated
layered movie based off of two issues
yeah the Days of Future past or a
language issue
the comic book writer apocalypse is like
that and they're gonna make one movie
anyway this is where we start to [ __ ]
about a movie that hasn't even been made
yet what one thing this movie did
setting aside the post-credits sequence
that I certainly appreciate and that
comic book movies don't seem to want to
do anymore is that it felt complete it
felt like this this story finished being
told which in the world of comic book
movies we're not really getting anymore
and I'm starting to get very concerned
by that fact the sort of fear that the
comic book movies are becoming more like
comic book issues where it yes they
never really end it's never a full story
it's always okay we're gonna drop this
cliffhanger because you need to come yet
for the makeup shoot yeah the next
chapter we're glad you had fun but we
got to push the next issue and you never
give people too resolution as a result
of that mean what the latest spider-man
movie was the perfect case again I still
haven't seen it but that I mean I've
heard that but you know aside aside from
this is the this is one of the only
recent comic book movies that I can
think of a side from Dark Knight Korra
that Dark Knight Rises that feels like a
definitive wrap-up closure mm-hmm we can
walk away now that was that was very
much the feeling that I was getting it
um at the very end when we saw the
cameos from the older cast particularly
the ones who weren't advertised that's
not in June right
I loved seeing those two together I that
was mine among all of the many many
problems with the third x-men movie my
least favorite was how Cyclops was
handled yeah so I I loved seeing you
know I was kind of waiting for once he
woke up and we were seeing all those
characters I was like we're gonna see
James Marsden this sucka s stop again
we're gonna see him and I I did a little
jump for joy I just can't wait to see
them frankly in the 80s
I enjoyed the 60s loved what they did of
the 70s which I didn't think was
overplayed by the way I was I really
don't want to see my character of disco
dancing I loved and where was better
beanies
oh dear oh I guess I guess that about
wraps it up on that one so thanks for
stopping by guys thanks for seeing the
movie with me and thanks for talking
about it thank you and until next time
this council is a jerk